now Brazilians also go to the polls
after a highly polarized presidential
election campaign that's prompted fears
of violence opinion polls give a clear
advantage to the leftist former
president Luis inacio Lula de Silva and
the right-wing incumbent Jaya bolsonaro
has hinted he might not accept a defeat
our correspondent Johan Ramirez sent us
this report on the election from Rio de
Janeiro
Fernanda Cipriano wants Lula da Silva to
be her president
she lost her job after getting covered
and says the financial support she gets
is not enough
she's putting her hopes in Lula's
Promises of a left-wing government
focusing on social issues
if Lula wins the election we will get
everything back people who live on the
streets will get jobs housing
everything they don't have now
but people are split
and you can also find people on the
streets of Rio who want more of
right-wing president jair bolsonaro
went through a very difficult time
it is not fair that people don't want to
give him the chance to do a good job
again
Brazil like all countries in the world
is starting to grow now after the
pandemic
starting to develop
ment and our government needs to show
its work right now starting again
Brazilians have a difficult decision to
make on Sunday
although there are nine other candidates
in this election it is all about Lula
and bolsonaro according to recent polls
Lula is ahead by more than 15 points and
bolsonaro has said if he doesn't win in
the first round it would be because
something was wrong with the process
some say this would put Brazil's
democracy at risk
yet
this is the first time in Brazil we have
a president who says we cannot trust the
results
there is a lot of fear that bolsonaro
will not recognize the results
and that he will mobilize the armed
forces and the police to remain in
office
and yet Mauricio Santoro says campaigns
and voters are largely focused on more
immediate concerns
of course in this election the economy
is the most important issue even more
important than the pandemic issues such
as unemployment hunger and the social
impact of all these problems for the
poorest people in Brazil are at the
center of the campaign
locals on Rios Copacabana beach know
their future will be determined by the
results of these elections most voters
will be thinking of what it will mean
for day-to-day issues but experts will
be watching closely to see if Brazil's
democracy might be in danger
well I'm joined Now by my colleague
Christiane romalo from DW's Portuguese
for Brazil service Christiana good to
see you polls indicate that Lula may
even here have a shot at an outright
victory victory in the first round today
what do you think
hi Anthony yes uh it's true according to
the last polls from yesterday night uh
Lula could really win in the first turn
today he has 50 percent of the intention
of the votes and he has a fear 14
percent of advantage over bolsonaro but
everything remains really undecided we
cannot predict exactly it will depends
on also how many people is going to
appear to vote today
interesting on on the turnout Point how
would you describe the atmosphere in the
country ahead of this vote well the
atmosphere is quite polarized the
research is the pools indicated that 10
almost 10 percent of the people cannot
appear to vote because they are afraid
of political violence and this would be
really important especially for the
voters for Lula because they they live
in the most poor places in Brazil so
it's it's quite possible that this could
be a turning point in this election but
let's wait and see
and out of the question everyone's
asking unfortunately if the polls are
right and bolsonaro loses will he go
peacefully will he accept a defeat here
well he has seen many many times he has
said that he's not going to accept a
defeat
and also he has been campaigning against
all this whole electoral process saying
that this is not fair this is not a
really true and that has many problems
so he's trying to do the credibility
this process and although he has himself
he was a voted elected four years ago
from exactly the same Democratic process
that we have in Brazil many analysts say
he is not going to have enough support
to go in for a military cup so with I
guess that also the campaign prolula in
this last
days and weeks are winning a new wave of
support from many segments of the
society so I guess the tendency is that
he has to accept but when we cannot say
that his supporters that are now going
to encourage it by bolsonaro from this
hate speeches we'll try to get some kind
of violence in the next days so much
riding on it so much tension in the
build up uh thanks so much for your
thoughts at this moment Cristiano
Ronaldo thank you